[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
then at what is on the front pages time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political editor of the guardian
peppercura and the political editor of
the sum Harry Cole with us from now
until just before midnight welcome both
of you as ever we turn our attention
first of all to the front pages
the front of the eye is on the
escalating crisis in Sudan with the
headline Brits face a three-day drive to
reach Royal Navy ships well the Metro
simply says get them out
the guardian is reporting the CBI
admitting its future is in doubt after
failing to filter out toxic people
the financial times reporting the Prime
Minister and Chancellor are pressed to
deliver on pledges to mend ties with
business
The Daily Mail with a similar story
business blasts rishi's own goal over
tourist tax
the express headline reads a pledge from
our pm to Horton Britain's women
and did the earth move for you the start
reporting on a space tourist signing no
Nookie waivers as the paper calls it to
prevent sperm mutations
well by scanning the QR code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us but let's
head straight to our guests then mixed
bag of front pages uh it would appear
but let's kick off Harry with the eye uh
stranded Britain's facing what they're
describing as a three-day Drive in Sudan
to reach Royal Navy warships effectively
from the capital possibly to Port Sudan
where the understanding is there's a
reconnaissance team they're working out
options on how to get people out
um but this is tricky as it not
extremely
um and we've already had a fairly
hair-raising
um sort of 96 hours trying to extract
um the foreign office uh representations
in Sudan their dependents
um their families and that's you know
just a couple of dozen of people and
that was pretty Lively by all accounts
um successfully took off bar one
dependent um Sunday so that was pretty
hair-raising but the big question now
for the government is right okay you've
got your your people out what about
those four up to 4 000 British citizens
there and um for reasons that I don't
profess to understand yet um because I
have relatively new to this like pretty
much everyone else is we have seem to
have a lot more people
um in Sudan than say the United States
or the French or the Germans so there's
a significant number of Brits and it
sounds like to me tonight that a seventh
Cobra meeting has been held I think it's
the third or fourth one that the Prime
Minister has chaired
um and they are looking at all possible
options to try and get people out but if
you're not going to airlift them and the
airport and Khartoum is out of action
now after those flights are taken off
um you have to start looking at other
ways and yeah as the eye point out if
you're going to try and use um RAF sorry
Royal Navy warships which are apparently
on their way to the region or in the
region or on the way to the to Sudan's
Coast
um you know it's going to be tricky and
it's going to be a hairy ride and you
know we've already seen diplomats coming
under attack normal citizens and
civilians um that could get very nasty
very quickly
yes and we certainly heard Andrew
Mitchell Pippa in the comments today
that the published figure for the number
of Nationals there is 400 but if you add
dual citizens that rises to 4 000 and
the acceptances if you have a British
passport you'd be treated in exactly the
same way whichever group you belong to
and the foreign office has received
registered Communications from 2000 but
as Harry said there there is criticism
of why you get out 30 people or roughly
30 people who could have helped with the
evacuation from on the ground before you
get any of these people out and has the
government been slow on this
well it's been a situation which the
British government has been
um aware of from the beginning I mean I
was abroad for James cleverley last week
the foreign secretary and right at the
beginning of the week he was taking
calls in Sudan was aware of the
situation on the ground and crisis
meetings were already being held in the
foreign office in London
um and I know a lot of comparisons have
been made with other uh other nations
and how for example the French and the
Germans have got people out much more
quickly but the comparison is not really
a fair one because we have as Harry says
thousands of British and dual National
citizens uh there who would need to be
many of them need help to um to get out
to be evacuated whereas some of our
European Partners have um have a match
of hundreds or in some cases dozens so
it's just a different scale of operation
um I think one development which has
happened in the last couple of hours is
that the two sides in the in the Civil
War
um the two sort of military General have
declared a three-day ceasefire now there
was a brief ceasefire on Sunday which
allowed some of those other countries to
um to evacuate some of their some of
their citizens and if this 3D CCR holds
and of course it's only just been
announced
um we're not sure about the details of
it yet and there's a big question mark
over whether it could hold uh when the
when the two sides are involved in in
frequent skirmishes and clashes in the
streets of cartoon elsewhere
um but if it does then that possibly
allows another opportunity for British
people who've been told currently
because there is an evacuation plan for
them in place just yet to stay indoors
to potentially join for example un
convoys out to Port Sudan where this
plane is waiting and where there's an
expectation that um that uh British Navy
ships might also be there ready to ready
to take people out but there's a lot of
this in that there's a lot of
hypotheticals
um and the foreign office emergency
crisis response team will be working uh
overnight
um to try and make sure that they've got
some of the answers questions should an
opportunity arise to get people out yes
indeed in that 72 hours a festival
announced by the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken should be starting at 11
p.m in the evening then on Monday that's
UK time uh 12 midnight local time and
certainly we heard from James heapey the
Armed Forces Minister earlier this
evening Harry on this do you have to get
yourself to Port Sudan in the east of
the country on your own he suggested
that a un Convoy from Khartoum had
reached Port Sudan without trouble and a
number of other British Nationals had
made it to Ports five of them ending up
on a ship that docked in Jeddah in Saudi
Arabia but of course they didn't
necessarily come from the capital where
we where we've seen such Fierce fighting
um but it's very you know very scary
Prospect for the families back home and
those Nationals who are there who might
have to make their way as the eye puts
it
um on a three-day drive across a
war-torn country
yeah Andrew Mitchell was in the comments
the development Minister
um was up up earlier and he basically
said you know if you uh you know it may
be your own personal discretion where
you decide to make a run for it and it's
going to be on your own risk which isn't
the most reassuring thing I've ever
heard of Minister say at the splashbox
but um an incredibly tricky situation
and um yeah as the ISA it's it's a rough
ride
okay let's move on to the Metro Pippa
um Abbott comments anti-semitic and have
no place in party this is secure starma
that's their headline uh what happens to
her now
well that's a big the big question I
don't think anybody quite knows yet I
mean this is in relation to comments
which Diana but to me in the letter to
the Observer newspaper which contained
anti-semitic comments and uh immediately
uh apologized for and gave a rather I
think an excuse to which I think a lot
of people have struggled to get to grips
with which was that was that it was the
first draft of um of a letter I'm not
sure how that necessarily uh makes any
makes it any better but regardless
um she had the whip the liberal whip
suspended
um and uh investigation has been
launched through Labor's new um
complaints process which was set up by
kyostarma
um when he took over the party
um and stammer is has been very it's
been unequivocal he's he said that you
know it's anti-Semitism she had to she
had to be suspended uh they of course
have got a um a zero tolerance approach
times anti-Semitism now in the week of
the Jeremy corbyn era where it was such
a huge problem for um for the party
internally and and also reputationally
um I think uh there was a real sort of
uh expectation um when Starman took over
that the sort of the top thing he needed
to do was sort out the party internally
into ridiculous reputation fantasemitism
a lot of people thought he'd struggled
to do that but he's been pretty ruthless
thus far and Diana but is no exception
and what now happens and how long that
takes is the crucial thing because of
course we're potentially a year or so
away from a general election and Libra
is selecting candidates in seats the
Assumption had been that she would want
to run again she's been around since I
think 1987 or she was she became an MP
for the first time she's been around a
long time but had suggested that she
might want to stand again if she is
doesn't have the labor whip though if
the investigation goes on for some time
and there's a you know there's there's
cases that Nick Brown is one of them
former labor Chief whip who had the whip
suspended from him as well that these
cases seemed to investigations seem to
sort of drag on for quite a long time
um then obviously she wouldn't be in a
position where she she could stand as a
labor candidate
um
I think you know we have to see how
quickly that process that process takes
place but you know labor will not be
welcoming a reminder that uh that has
been ensued now
um uh a reminder to the public that it
did have a problem
um with anti-Semitism and stamina will
be doing absolutely everything to
reassure people that that is in the
party's past
um and those days are behind them and
two quick questions then to you Harry on
this I mean is the accusation that she's
seeing race and therefore racism only
through the prism of the color of
someone's skin and secondly we remember
what happened to you know the David
gorks of this world under Boris Johnson
in the conservative party you know the
effect that if he effectively got felt
like he got rid of those anti-brexit
more left-leaning conservatives is this
is the same happening here that actually
secure is trying to get rid of the the
left of the labor party
I think if you'd ask Boris Johnson if he
had his time again he might have got rid
of a few more of his critics in the um
in the Tory party when he had the
opportunity to do back in 2019
um I've in fact he led a whole sway them
back in which I suspect is what labor
will do
um if you look at some of the MPS who
have caught themselves in race Rouse
they've been you know sort of given a
bit of a Penance on the back bench
allowed back Dan that was a really
tricky one first timer she is a labor
institution she is you know a
Trailblazer Blazer in her in her own
right completely so I wonder whether she
gets a certain amount of leeway because
of her history of record-breaking
um sort of career now look this is not
the first time that Diane's got into
trouble is it I mean I can remember
writing in 2012 I think it was when she
tweeted that white people love playing
divide and Rule and that was a you know
an outrage and an apology and then
there's been other outrage in the body
remember when she said that you know on
the whole that she thought Chairman Mao
was a net positive rather than a you
know murderous communist dictator so
she's never been far from controversy
and there's been a feeling in labor land
that in sort of opposition land that
she's almost been taunting uh the
leadership to try and kick her out
um she I believe she signed one of those
NATO anti-nato letters at the beginning
of the Ukraine conflict and quickly rode
back on that so it's almost felt like
this has been coming to her head for a
while but I'll be amazed
um if labor expelled or perhaps blocked
um you know the their first black female
MP from from running if she wished to I
wonder where there's an elegant fudge
might be come up where she she just
decides to stand down
um but it's clear that there are serious
questions to answer from from from what
she wrote on Sunday the amazing excuse
you came up with was which was oh this
was the first draft I accidentally sent
the first draft which is admitting she's
had the comments but admitted that she
sent the version before someone had
given her reality check and that this is
mad you cannot say this and big
questions I think for the Observer as
well of why on Earth they you know they
publish on the letters page Without
Really drawing any attention to it and
um at best they missed a scoop at worst
I they missed um perhaps something
rather unsavory that you wouldn't
necessarily want printed in a pages of a
newspaper without some form of context
yes we will we'll try to get to the
bottom of that um I've got the sun in
front of me and the guardian so I'm
going to stick to your own papers if
that's all right not least because Harry
this is an exclusive by you as you might
as well answer this which is what what
happens to sue gray she of course who
investigated Boris Johnson in partygate
but wants to work for secure stama so
what's your story yeah bit of a headache
brewing for for care this might be the
worst of all scenarios for him
um
a caution that this is what Whitehall
figures and people inside government
believe is going to happen quite soon it
is very much their view rather than the
sun's view but it a lot of people think
that actually they're going to throw the
book at Sue gray and actually her sort
of secret meetings with labor and the
run-up to her sort of leaked
announcement that she was in line to be
late to Kia establish Chief of Staff got
down very badly in in Humphrey land and
it looks like that the completely
toothless but advisory Watchdog that
recommends on um on uh you know future
appointments for senior officials and
politicians looks like it could say yeah
you can take a job at Kirsten but you
can do so essentially after the next
election which defeats the entire point
of stalma hiring her which was to lead
their transition into government so um a
bit of a shooting in the foot there if
that if that comes to pass and the lead
for the guardian then Pippa the CBI
admitting admitting rather that its
future might be in doubt after failing
to filter out toxic people uh tell us
the latest then
this is the letter from the president of
the CBI Brian McBride and follows a
series of Revelations by my colleague at
the guardian Anna Isaac
um about uh about uh poor behavior in
the CBI sexual harassment drug taking
um and uh and two separate examples or
allegations of rape which uh you know
really really quite um quite disturbing
and Brian McBride admits that the
organization had failed to filter out
what he describes as culturally toxic
people and of course that had terrible
consequences as as I've just set out and
really the the future of the
organization and this has been Britain's
foremost lobbying Group business
lobbying group for the last 50 or 60
years
um the future is really hanging in the
balance now they've already had about 50
of their missed high profile uh member
organizations organizations like John
Lewis and NatWest just to name a couple
um either suspend or permanently leave
at the CBI and both government and the
labor party have also suspended uh
contact relations with those uh with
with them and they've suspended their
membership and policy activity until
um extraordinary meeting in June at
which their members will vote
um on their future and their purpose
um you know it is an existential crisis
for the CBI
um and it's I think it's sort of you
know the worrying aspect of it and
several senior uh business people men
and women have have highlighted this is
that it somehow puts people puts women
off
um going into business thinking that the
sort of you know the awful old troops
about what that world used to be like
the city used to be like for women
um are in fact still in place
um but cbis has obviously got you know a
lot of work to do if it's going to
survive
um and uh and you know it's not just its
own its own reputation but but the
reputation of you know big business more
generally that it's going to have to is
going to have to try and restore